It's the final option. The time step has to be smaller than half of Δx² divided by thermal diffusivity.
Let me explain why--if the time step was exactly equal to 1/2  (Δx)² divided by thermal diffusivity.
This expression would equal to and our result would be -1.
What would happen is that our initial temperature distribution would be reflected
after the first time step where it was 1 before, it would be -1 after,
and it's easy to compute that where it was -1 before, it would be 1 after.
The next time step would undo this reflection and here
the blue distribution again and so on and so on.
We would see infinite oscillation. We would see oscillation but no decay.
If age is smaller than 1/2 this ratio, this expression is smaller than 2.
If age is smaller than 1/2 times this ratio, this expression is smaller than 2,
we're subtracting less, so the result is larger than -1.
Oh a new temperature, 1/2 to 1 times step at position 0 is not -1 but a little more than that,
and of course, it's similar for the others.
So you see that when it totally reflecting our function, we're losing a little,
and with the next time step, we again are going to lose a little, so that's going to work out well.
As soon as age is smaller than 1/2 this ratio, we're going to see decay,
but to stop that oscillation during the decay, we indeed have to pick age smaller than
1/4 of that ratio, so that we're subtracting less than 1.
This condition shows that our method is really poor.
If you use a spatial subdivision that's finite by a factor of 2,
we have to use a time step that's smaller by a factor of .4.
Hopefully, this reminds you of Unit 3, the recovered implicit methods to deal with such instabilities.
For partial differential equations, implicit methods maybe unavoidable.